emma scream queens is totally having a
moment on tick-tock right now i mean
would you ever want to bring chanel back
in some form back to the screen
i'm always thinking about ways we could
bring chanel back to the screen
chanel
i'd like to introduce you to jennifer
i'm sorry kappa doesn't participate in
the make-a-wish foundation oh but you do
now
i feel like i'm ready to
to have her rise again i don't know but
but it's not up to me but no i mean it's
funny because
that show is now so long ago and i i
still see things coming up on my
instagram of people just kind of like
loving it and parroting it and like
doing tick tocks and all that these are
my minions i don't know their names i
don't want to know their names they are
known as
chanel number two
chanel number three
number five
i'm chanel number one obvi it just makes
me so happy that she's really stood the
test of time so that's so many iconic
lives that's why too
awesome and john you and emma of course
actually have a mutual bestie her scream
queen's co-star leah michelle uh it was
so awesome seeing you guys reunite for a
spring awakening uh do you see that gang
getting back together for another
project like ever or at all i'm thinking
maybe we could get like a season of
horror story with you leah and emma
let's do it i'm in
i'll i'll i'll
i'll say yeah i'm saying yes here folks
you heard it here first i want you guys
back on stage i want to see you guys on
stage i know i would love to do
something with that with that gang again
i mean like doing the reunion has
obviously kind of reinvigorated all of
us to keep more in touch yeah and so
there's an epic spring awakening text
thread that you know i always wake up to
like 50 texts and i'm like wait who is
oh it's the spring awakening text right
yep it's alive again
yes and i agree with you emma it would
be amazing to see you guys back on stage
together in something so hopefully we
can manifest that today
this would be the baby's room the house
it's been listed for a while why hasn't
anyone bought it
there was an incident we uh we don't
want to know
we do
emma obviously this movie revolves
around your character and this newborn i
mean how did um how did you use your own
experience as a new mom for this role
and did it kind of unlock any new fears
for you off screen
oh my goodness um well i mean for me i i
read this and it was funny because
everybody was like nervous to send it to
me because i had like just had a baby
and they're like they're like i don't
know what you're gonna think of this i
don't know if you'll be down for this
you know because i know you just had a
baby but but i i i loved it and i hadn't
i don't i don't think i've played a mom
before and i was like i don't know this
just felt like kind of a really like
interesting way to do that for the first
time and i felt like there was a lot i
could bring to it having just had a
child so obviously that like just rocks
your perspective on things and so to me
i was like you know like let's do it and
and i thought it'd be so fun and i was
lucky enough to get to have my son on
set with me so you know it's like i was
you know working all day and it's
obviously you know heavy subject matter
but he was like you know the best spot
of my day and my mom would always bring
him to have lunch with all of us and and
so it was it was really nice and it was
it was it was really it was a nice
experience despite how horrifying the
movie looks like when i saw the trailer
i was like i'm so scared i was like we
had so much fun doing it i didn't
realize it was gonna be so scary i was
watching like this like classic like
just hanging over my face just waiting
for something to pop out but but on that
note i am curious what do you think is
the first project of yours emma that
rhodes will watch when he's old enough
i'm sure it's not abandoned
i mean that's a good question i feel
like with the internet it's like i'm
gonna have to put parental lock so he's
not watching american horror story when
he's like six
that push nancy drew or aquamarine i
have like there's like some like
eight-year-olds that have come up here
like i love horror story and i'm like
hopefully kevin and not like you know
like some of the really scary ones
but yeah no i mean yeah i think we'll
stick to aquamarine as his first one
that feels that feels great
what about the boy
what happened to him
he was ignored
blamed for the mother's death
[Music]
i gotta tell you i am a scaredy cat so
you can imagine how stressed i was
watching this movie
i'm not sure if you guys are getting
that reaction from a lot of people today
but uh it's so amazing to see you guys
both in the horror genre again and emma
i feel like you know scream cleans uh an
american horror story i mean that's
pretty hard to top what was it about
abandon that you just had to say yes
well i from the moment i got the script
i was so intrigued by the title and what
i loved about it was as i was reading it
you know having done like horror horror
comedy like you know all different kind
of
sub genres of the genre i just felt like
this really stood out as more of like a
psychological thriller and
i met with the
writer and director spencer squire and
he really wanted to make
something in this realm but that was
super thoughtful and and i really think
he did like i just i i finished reading
the script thinking like wow like this
is so interesting and entertaining but
also you know i feel like it it says
something and and what that says is i
feel like anyone who sees it is going to
take away something different and it
really like i don't know i just i
couldn't shake it like i was thinking
about it long after i read it
it definitely lingered i felt that too
and john obviously you're no stranger to
horror films either i would just say
this one matches up uh you know to 10
cloverfield lane or even hush
well i i feel like i'm really drawn to
uh to horror films that
like those films and like this one are
really intimate um that if you kind of
if you if you pare it down
you can almost cut out the supernatural
element and you still have a really
intriguing and engaging story about this
young couple in a crisis you know it
reminded me of of um you know like of a
great drama like ordinary people or like
a familial drama that's really just
about people struggling to connect and
missing each other and
beginning not to trust each other um
which is scary enough on its own but
then you layer in this this the threat
of supernatural element within and it
goes to this you know a whole other
level um and that's kind of what i
always look for is is are the characters
interesting because you know there's
lots of great horror movies out there
but i i i kind of as an actor i'm just
drawn to
what are the people going through and is
that compelling in and of itself i'm
sure you're also drawn to like who
you're going to be working with too
because i feel like i'm always curious
on movies like this what is the vibe
actually like on set like do you guys
get pretty method or is it way more
light-hearted than we can imagine you
know between takes we were so method
you know i don't know so not method no
we were not like chit-chatting like
i don't know reading our books like girl
grabbing hanging and then we'd be like
oh hold on okay like hold on like stop
stop
we love that we had a really great green
room because we did film the whole thing
on location in one house so we really
were in this farmhouse for a month um
making this movie and there was one room
that was just kind of it was like the
the hideout where em and i could go and
hang out it was basically like the
all-purpose green room in the hair and
makeup room and it really was the
sanctuary for us um in between takes a
place to go and kind of joke around and
um and and decompress and um i had such
fond memories of hanging out in that
room there was a chair in the corner
that i would sit in and then across the
room and have this couch and emma would
would be in between uh in between
reading because she's a voracious reader
as everybody knows i'm sure um and in
between paragraphs i feel like you know
we would just gossip and gab and have a
blast it was really fun and we needed it
because obviously the film is so intense
we needed a safe place to go
[Music]